the federal mass mandate for
transportation which may not be dead
just yet the biden administration says
it will appeal a judge's decision to
strike down the mandate and although
it's not clear if the mandate would be
immediately reinstated if the government
wins that appeal errol barnett is
following all these latest developments
for you he's at the reagan national
airport which is just outside washington
era it's like that temptation song ball
of confusion that's what the world is
today hey-hey
and that ball continues to roll gail
good morning look the cdc says amid a
surge of covert in several states across
the country a masking requirement
indoors for travelers remains necessary
and that is why it asks the department
of justice late on wednesday to make an
official appeal but all of this leaves
us travelers stuck in the middle of what
is a growing legal battle that certainly
carries the potential to reach the
supreme court
just two days after some flyers removed
their face masks mid-flight a legal
challenge from the justice department
could potentially bring the federal mass
mandate back we're all ready for it to
be over but we want to ensure that our
public health experts are able to take
steps if needed in the future as of
thursday it remains up to passengers to
decide whether to wear masks on public
transportation though the sudden rule
change monday led to confusion with some
cities like new york and philadelphia
still requiring masks on trains buses
and in airports in a statement the cdc
defended the mask mandate saying at this
time an order requiring masking in the
indoor transportation corridor remains
necessary for the public health a trump
appointed federal judge in florida
struck down the mandate monday saying
the cdc exceeded its authority and
didn't follow rulemaking procedures and
this comes at a time when covert 19
cases are surging in parts of the
country the problem with air travel cbs
news contributor dr david ager says that
while airplanes have strong filtration
systems it may not be enough for high
risk travelers those people
will have more of a difficulty going out
in public with a potential being exposed
they can get very ill which is a very
real concern for brian vastag of hawaii
he traveled to alaska for treatment for
his autoimmune disorders i am constantly
assessing my risk i'm not going to know
is there somebody on the plane who's
sick right now
and we all know pandemic fatigue is
setting in for so many but this decision
certainly carries risks for the bide
administration what's on the line well
the future influence of the cdc and the
federal government's ability tony should
there be another virus another variant
to make health regulations
still a high-stakes situation earl thank
you very much